you have to ask yourself inside a
company where do you allow for crazy
ideas for real true risk to take place
risk that will mostly all fail in edison
had you know hundreds of failures on his
way to creating the elements inside a
light bulb that's another way to think
about it the Magellan or Columbus can
you imagine today Magellan you know
receiving any money from the venture
capitalists you know just telling that I
don't have a map I don't know what I'm
heading for I just believe you know just
I can bring a lot of you know a gold or
spices from from from this trip we don't
want this risk it we just believe that
it okay fine we have we have so much
well surround us why should we take in
risk and and and and it's kind of a
complacency so much was invented before
we can just benefit from using it's only
an ability and willingness an appetite
to take risk can secure future rules